الامريكي يوقع مرسومه عقوبات ضد
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه وتل ابيب ترد
بغضب الولايات المتحده تقدم صفقه لوقف
اطلاق نار دائم في القطاع فهل تنجح بينما
قطر تعلن عن اقتراب موعد الهدنه وبشكل غ
قريب ومريب زيلنسكي يقيل رئيس اداره الامن
القومي الاوكراني والاتحاد الاوروبي يحقق
الاختراق الاهم في اجتماعه لاجل كياف
والعديد من شركات الاسلحه الامريكيه ترفض
توقيع العقود مع
البنتاجون ابو اليمن يرد على
الفور بعد ليله وصفت بالصعبه تحت وقع
الضربات الامريكيه لم يتاخر الرد اليمني
حيث افادت المصادر بان ابو اليمن كان قد
اطلق صاروخا من احد معسكر محافظه اب
باتجاه البحر هذا وقالت هيئه عمليه
التجاره البحريه البريطانيه انها تلقت
تقريرا عن حادثه على بعد 57 ميلا بحريا
غربيا ميناء الحديده في اليمن ولفتت الى
ان الانفجار وقع على مسافه بعيده على
ميمنه السفينه هناك اعلنت القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه توجيه ضربه ضد طائرات مسيره
ومحطه تحكم ارضيه تابعه للجيش اليمني
ونقلت رويترز عن مسؤول امريكي ان سفينه
تابعه للبحريه الامريكيه اسقطت ثلاث
طائرات مسيره ايرانيه وصاروخ بالستيا
مضادا للسفن تابعا لحكومه صنعاء في خليج
عدن واضافت القياده ان قواتها دمرت مركبا
مفخخا مسيرا تابعا لحكومه صنعاء في البحر
الاحمر ليخرج زعيم صنعاء عبد الملك الحوثي
ويؤكد ان هناك جهزيه قويه لاستهداف اي
سفينه وجهتها نحو تل ابيب كاشفا عن حصيله
عمليه جيش بلاده خلال اسبوع بعشر عمليات
في البحر الاحمر ومضيق باب المندب استهدفت
السفن المرت البطه بالعدو العبري
والامريكي والبريطاني وكان مسؤولون هنود
قالوا ان نيو ديلهي نشرت ما لا يقل عن 12
سفينه حربيه قرب البحر الاحمر لتوفير
الحمايه من القراصنه واضاف المسؤولون ان
البحريه الهنديه قد قامت بالتحقيق مع اكثر
من 250 سفينه وزورق في الوقت نفسه الذي
تركز فيه القوه الغربيه على هجمات الجيش
اليمني ولم تنضم الهند الى قوه المهام
التي تقودها الولايات المتحده في البحر
الاحمر وليس لديها اي سفن حرب هناك
ولنتصور كروسيت تو ان الضربات الامريكيه
البريطانيه ضد الجيش اليمني قلصت نشاطهم
الى النصف لكن من المستحيل وقف هجماتهم
بالكامل متابعا ان مهمه الاتحاد الاوروبي
في البحر الاحمر ستشمل ثلاث سفن على الاقل
احداها سفينه ايطاليه اضافه الى الاستطلاع
الجوي والاقمار الصناعيه اللوجستي بالعوده
الى الولايات المتحده حيث وقع الرئيس جو
بايدن امرا تنفيذيا لاتخاذ اجراءات جديده
تستهدف الانشطه التي تقوض السلام والامن
في الضفه الغربيه بما في ذلك استخدام
العقوبات واشارت الاداره الى ان الجوله
الاولى من العقوبات جار تقديمها وشملت
اربعه اشخاص هناك قال متحدث البيت الابيض
جون كيربي انه لا توجد خطه لاستهداف
المسؤولين الحكوميين العبريين بالعقوبات
حاليا مضيفا انه تم ابلاغ الحكومه العبريه
بالامر التنفيذي المتعلق الضفه الغربيه
قبيل اعلانه هنا نتصفح
المصدر ليرد وزير الامن القومي العبري
ايتمار بن غفير انه حان الوقت لتعيد
الولايات المتحده النظر في سياستها تجاه
الضفه الغربيه مضيفا ان بايدن مخطئ فيما
يتعلق بالمواطنين العبريين والمستوطنين
الابطال هذا وتعمل الولايات المتحده على
تحقيق وقف دائم لاطلاق النار في القطاع
عبر من ثلاث مراحل ونشرت صحيفه ول ستريت
جورنال مسوده الاتفاق وقالت ان المفوضين
ينتظرون رد الفصائل فيما نقل موقع اكسيوس
عن مسؤول امريكي ان مراجعه الخيارات
المتعلقه بالاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه
كانت من القضايا التي طل وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن من الوزاره النظر
فيها واضاف الموقع ان بلينكن طلب ايضا
مراجعه شكل دوله فلسطينيه منزوعه السلاح
بناء على نماذج اخرى في العالم على ذات
السياق قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه
ماجد الانصاري ان تلبيب وافقت على مقترح
وقف اطلاق النار في القطاع لافتا الى انه
لدى الدوحه تاكيد ايجابي اولي من الفصائل
نحو المقترح وقال مسؤولون لصحيفه و ستريت
جورنال عدد من العقبات الخطيره تجعل
التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق صعبا ولكن في حال
تم التغلب عليها يمكن التوصل للاتفاق في
غضون اسبوع الى عره
ايام الدعم الاوروبي يصل
اخيرا دول الاتحاد الاوروبي تجتمع
والمستشار الالماني اولاف تشولز يقف
مطالبا الشركاء الاوروبيين بتعزيز دعمهم
العسكري لاوكرانيا محذرا من انه لا يمكن
الاعتماد على المانيا وحدها في ذلك هناك
وبعد تجاوز عقبه هنغاريا التي لطالما عرضت
دعما طويلا الاماد ل كياف تحقق الاختراق
الاهم في قمه بروكسل وتوافق قاده الاتحاد
الاوروبي على تخصيص 50 مليار يورو
كمساعدات اضافيه لاوكرانيا على مدى اربع
سنوات كما بحث الزعماء الاوروبيون سبل
تسريع المساعده العسكريه المقدمه مالك ياب
وكان مجلس الاوروبي قد اكد الحاجه الملحه
للتعجيل بتوصيل الذخائر والصواريخ لدعم
الجيش الاوكراني وهنا يتحدث المصدر تتحدث
تحديدا عن تجاوز العقبه الهنجريه وموافقه
الاتحاد الاوروبي بكامل اعضائه ال 27 على
التقديم المساعدات حزمه المساعدات المقدمه
لاوكرانيا والتي تصل الى 50 مليار يورو
خلال السنوات الاربع المقبله فيما قال
منسق الاتصالات الا استراتيجيه في البيت
الابيض جون كوربي ان الولايات المتحده ليس
لديها بدائل للدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا بدون
موافقه الكونغرس على طلب الرئيس جو بايدن
من جانبها قالت صحيفه و ستريت جورنال ان
العديد من شركات الاسلحه الامريكيه ترفض
بعض العقود مع البنتاغون لتطوير انظمه
سلاح متقدمه لمواجهه التهديدات الخارجيه
خوفا من الخسائر الماديه وهنا صرح رئيس
الوفد الروسي في مفاوضات فيان حول الامن
العسكري والحد من التسلح كونستانتين جفري
لوف لقناه روسيا 24 ان الاتفاق التي وقعته
هولندا والمانيا وبولندا بشان انشاء ممر
عسكري لنقل القوات ما هي الا استفزازات
يريدون من خلالها نقل القوات والمعدات الى
بولندا ودول البلطيق اسرع بكثير على الرغم
من انه ليس لدينا اي نيه لمهاجمه او
استفزاز النيتو ومن الواضح انهم ياتون الى
هذا الاستفزاز وفق تعبيره على الارض
الاوكرانيه كان فلاديمير زيلينسكي وقع
مرسوما باقاله رومان سميني شينكو من منصب
رئيس اداره الامن القومي بجهاز الامن
الاوكراني بشكل غريب دون ذكر الاسباب فيما
ذكر الخبير البريطاني الكساندر مير كوريس
ان زيلينسكي جعل البلاد اقرب الى ازمه
سياسيه خطيره من خلال محاولته اقاله
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
فالوري زالو جني واضاف ماير كوريس ان
الرئيس يحاول التخلص من القائد العام لكن
الجنرال يقاومه ميدانيا اعلن الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان اوكرانيا
استخدمت نظام بطريات الامريكي لاسقاط
طائره روسيه عسكريه الاسبوع الماضي في
بلغراد وتوفي كل من فيها كما اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه القضاء على 805 عسكريين
اوكرانيين واسقاط 68 مسيره اوكرانيه على
مختلف المحاور خلال 24
[موسيقى]
ساعه